Новини дня «heute» з Мітрієм Cіріним
Доброго вечора всім!
Про спорт розповість Норберт Леман.
Найважливіші теми сьогодні:
Додатковий податок на прибутки під час кризи?
Бремен здійснює тиск у Федеральній раді й хоче змусити
нафтові концерни платити ще більше.
Нестача персоналу в авіакомпаніях та аеропортах
та, як наслідок, побоювання довгих черг
під час туристичного сезону й
скасування сотні рейсів.
Серйозні звинувачення в бік Трампа:
слідчий комітет стверджує, що колишній президент
винен у штурмі Капітолію.
Попри знижку на пальне ціни на бензин
залишаються на рекордному рівні,
тому в уряді Німеччини провадяться дискусії
щодо так званого «податку на надприбуток».
SPD та Зелені виступають «за», FDP - «проти».
З ініціативи Бремену цю тему
обговорюють тепер і у Федеральній раді.
Розгляньмо детальніше, про що йдеться.
Податок на надприбуток - вид спеціальних податків.
Він накладається на ту частину прибутку, що
виходить за межі нормального прибутку,
якщо порівняти з докризовими роками.
Наприклад, нафтові концерни.
Ці 4 гіганти вдвічі збільшили свій прибуток
у першому кварталі
порівняно з минулим роком.
Приблизно з 15 до 34 млрд доларів США.
Детальніше про дискусію - Катаріна Вайсґербер.
Ціни на заправках й надалі високі.
Знижки на пальне ніби й не було,
ціни зростають майже так само швидко,
як і знизилися 10 днів тому.
Мені доводиться заправляти авто щотижня й
щоразу платити більше 100 євро.
Це все взагалі не тішить.
Можна було б докласти більше зусиль,
щоб знижки стосувалися не концернів,
а саме громадян.
Нафтові компанії отримують
величезні прибутки через війну в Україні.
Таких «бенефіціарів» під час війни і кризи
варто обкладати додатковим податком,
щоб вони також фінансували мільярдні пакети допомоги.
Сьогодні Бремен подав пропозицію
щодо такого податку до Федеральної ради.
Ціна сирої нафти дещо зросла, але не настільки.
Натомість нафтові транснаціональні компанії
набили власні кишені
завдяки збільшенню різниці між ціною на пальне
та ціною сирої нафти.
У Федеральній раді пропозицію сприймають схвально,
хоча критика також лунає.
Може скластися прикре враження, що
уряд довільно та на основі короткострокових
політичних міркувань визначає,
які прибутки є доречними, а які - ні.
Може здатися, що уряд
порушує основні принципи
ринкової економіки.
Багато деталей досі незрозумілі,
наприклад, як дістатися до прибутків нафтових концернів.
Міжнародні енергетичні компанії та нафтові шейхи
заробляють величезні гроші.
І поки що тут, у Німеччині,
нам не так легко отримати з цього вигоду.
Пропозицію з Бремену розглянуть
на ﻿порядку денному у Берліні.
Це може спричинити нову суперечку
в «світлофорній» коаліції.
А ось рішення щодо так званого
Спецфонду для Бундесверу на суму 100 млрд євро
Федеральна рада вже ухвалила.
Запланована закупівля нових винищувачів,
кораблів і танків.
Ухвалено і підвищення мінімальної зарплати
з жовтня до 12 євро на годину.
Також: краще забезпечення прав громадян
щодо мінімальних стандартів доступу до інтернету.
Після 2 років пандемії бажання відпусток - величезне.
Літаком  - назустріч сонцю.
На туристичну галузь чекає чудове літо.
І справді: ажіотаж навколо квитків,
але виявляються і проблеми,
адже під час пандемії відбулися
масові скорочення персоналу.
Згідно з оцінками в цій галузі, у всій Німеччині
бракує близько 5500 працівників,
наприклад, під час реєстрації квитків,
транспортування валіз, серед бортпровідників.
Лише «Lufthansa» вимушена скасувати
майже 900 рейсів у липні.
Детальніше - Нікола Альбрехт.
Сильне незадоволення серед сотень пасажирів
сьогодні зранку в аеропорту Берлін-Бранденбурґ.
Несподівано були скасовані 22 рейси.
Причина: страйк персоналу лінії EasyJet
з вимогою кращих умов праці.
Невеликий попереджувальний страйк -
свідчення найбільшої проблеми в авіагалузі:
після 2 років пандемії бракує 5500 співробітників.
З одного боку, авіакомпанії скорочували персонал,
що зараз дається взнаки, тому що кількість авіаперевезень
відновлюється дуже швидко, попит дуже високий.
З іншого боку, скорочення робочого часу
призвело до того, що працівники авіакомпаній
шукали іншу роботу.
Наприклад, Юлія Зайдерер,
яка пропрацювала 13 років
бортпровідницею у «Lufthansa».
У пандемію робочий час скоротили і
організували все настільки погано,
що Юлія була змушена звільнитися.
Деякі колеги мали скорочений робочий час,
але при цьому працювали дуже багато.
В той час як інші, наприклад я,
взагалі не працювали півроку.
Юлія каже, що «Lufthansa» сама пропонувала
їй та іншим звільнитися.
Натомість зараз бракує персоналу,
власне у аеропортах, службах охорони.
Довгі черги, пропущені рейси
вже стали чимось звичним.
Через брак персоналу авіакомпанії
вже зараз скасували
понад 1000 рейсів у липні.
Оператори аеропортів тривожно очікують
періоду літніх відпусток.
Галузь авіації, особливо в Європі, дійсно має проблеми,
це стосується всіх великих аеропортів.
Нам слід проаналізувати внутрішні проблеми,
щоб побачити, що варто зробити для покращення становища.
Наразі пасажирам, чиї рейси не скасували,
варто бути в аеропорту якомога раніше.
Два дні, п’ять країн.
Канцлер Німеччини Шольц прибув з візитом
до Західних Балкан,
щоб знову дати кільком країнам
надію на вступ до ЄС.
Перший пункт призначення: Косово.
Після бесіди з Шольцом прем'єрміністр Курті заявив,
що до кінця цього року Косово
подасть заявку на членство в ЄС.
Шольц закликав Косово й Сербію
підписати угоду про взаємне визнання.
Він також наполягав на цьому в Белграді
під час зустрічі з президентом Сербії Вучичем,
на що останній відреагував з обуренням.
Також Шольц закликав країну змінити її курс,
спрямований на дружню політику з Росією.
Не всі злочини та звірства війни в Україні викрито,
однак деякі вже відомі.
Згідно з даними правозахисної організації
«Human Rights Watch»,
у березні російські військові вбили в Чернігові
десятки мирних жителів, а також застосували
заборонені касетні боєприпаси.
Але є також звинувачення в бік України.
Репортаж з місця подій - Юлія Гельд.
Руїна.
Це все, що лишилося у Віктора Шерештана.
Він прожив тут 33 роки.
Нічого не залишилося з того, що він мав.
Я думаю, було сім бомб.
Одна біля будинку,
а інша - біля аптеки.
Це були не єдині бомби в той час.
Чернігів перебував під обстрілом російських військових
майже п’ять тижнів.
Ракети та бомби перетворили будинки,
супермаркети й навіть лікарні на руїни.
Вони - як відкриті рани в центрі міста.
Белкіс Вілле розслідувала деякі атаки.
За словами експертки «Human Rights Watch»,
йдеться винятково про цивільні об’єкти,
а, отже, про ймовірні воєнні злочини.
Ми вважаємо напади незаконними.
У жодному з розслідуваних випадків не йдеться
про військової цілі,
що бодай якось виправдовувало б ці атаки.
Однак українських військових також критикують.
Згідно з даними організації «Human Rights Watch»,
для свого розміщення
вони послуговуються школами.
Йдеться про школи, розташовані в житлових районах.
Це мало фатальні наслідки в Чернігові.
Тут загинули щонайменше 3 осіб.
У будинку Віктора Шерештана військових не було.
Поблизу теж.
Шерештан впевнений, що
російським загарбникам було байдуже до людей.
Зараз в Україні перебувають
міністр сільського господарства
Ездемір і міністр охорони здоров’я Лаутербах.
Лаутербах відвідав кілька лікарень у Львові
і пообіцяв Україні медичну допомогу
в лікуванні постраждалих від війни.
У Києві Ездемір обговорив з
міністром сільського господарства України
можливі шляхи експорту зерна
попри блокування Росією портів на Чорному морі.
Йоганнес Гано, неподалік від Миколаєва.
Увесь світ чекає на українське зерно.
Яка ситуація щодо можливого експорту?
Наразі немає альтернатив експорту і
зняттю морської блокади
та транспортуванню вантажними кораблями.
25 млн тонн зерна зберігаються в портах плюс
новий врожай у щонайменше 50 млн тонн.
Україна спробувала скористатися вантажними потягами до Румунії,
але Росія розбомбила єдиний залізничний міст.
У напрямку Румунії вже стоять
понад 8 тисяч вантажівок,
кількість яких збільшується щодня,
їх неможливо швидко розвантажити.
Якщо скористатися іншими шляхами перевезень,
можна припустити, що Росія
бомбардуватиме і інші маршрути.
Щоб перевезти зерно вантажівками,
знадобилося б приблизно 2 млн вантажівок
і утворилася б черга на 30 000 км.
Зрозуміло, що це нереалістичне рішення, тому
альтернативи зняттю блокади немає.
Онлайн у додатку «ZDFheute» Ви знайдете
додаткову ﻿інформацію про
візити солідарності міністрів Ездеміра та Лаутербаха,
а також про допомогу Німеччини жертвам війни.
До новин з США.
Якщо потрібні ще якісь докази того,
що суспільство та демократія похитнулися,
то їх надали ще 6 січня 2021 року.
Розгніваний натовп прихильників Трампа
штурмував Капітолій США.
Результат: 10 загиблих, понад 140 поранених,
деякі з них у тяжкому стані.
На питання про винних
у цій небаченій раніше жахливій події
спробувала відповісти слідча комісія.
Про результати -
Бенджамін Деніел з Вашингтону.
Ці раніше не опубліковані відеозаписи
ще раз показують,
що багато прихильників Трампа,
які майже півтора роки тому
штурмували Капітолій США, були готові на все.
Що б там не було.
Ми готові померти за цю справу.
Жінка-поліцейський Керолайн Едвардс
була так тяжко поранена,
намагаючись захистити Капітолій,
що досі не може повернутися на роботу.
Те, що я побачила, було схоже на війну.
До цього я бачила подібне лише у кіно.
Обличчя моїх колег були закривавлені.
Я послизнулася на підлозі через калюжі крові.
Комітет опублікував, зокрема, свідчення
тодішнього генерального прокурора.
Він сказав Трампу,
що вважає теорію про вкрадені вибори
«нісенітницею».
І навіть дочка Трампа так вважає.
Я поважаю генпрокурора Барра,
тому приймаю його слова.
Для Дональда Трампа програні вибори - це
лише початок поширення
багатошарової теорії змови з метою
поставити себе вище за президентські вибори
і, таким чином,
просто викинути голоси мільйонів американців.
І все ж більшість республіканців
не хочуть у все це вірити.
Тому демократи роблять все можливе,
аби якомога найшвидше проводити розслідування.
Адже якщо вони втратять свою більшість
у Палаті представників
на проміжних виборах у листопаді,
це, безумовно, означатиме і кінець для слідчого комітету.
Хоча 6 січня 2021 року спроба Трампа
здійснити державний переворот провалилася,
його напад на демократію ще далекий від завершення.
Франція стоїть перед важливим політичним рішенням.
Незабаром після свого переобрання
президент Макрон тепер має побоюватися
за свою абсолютну більшість у парламенті.
Згідно з останніми опитуваннями,
союз лівих сил може навіть
відтіснити Макрона на друге місце
на виборах до парламенту у неділю.
З Парижу - Анна Файст.
Добрий день, я кандидатка 16 округу.
Перший тур відбудеться в неділю.
Ліва кандидатка Джулі Морі
полює на голоси заможних парижан
у шикарному районі,
де традиційно голосують за Макрона.
Він просто краще знається на економіці,
менше безробіття і, звичайно,
треба допомагати бідним,
але не будь-якою ціною.
Лівих такі заяви не відлякують.
Народ більше не хоче обирати Макрона
і його класову політику.
Морі переконана у правильному шляху Nupes,
нового союзу лівих,
комуністів, зелених та соціалістів,
які хочуть запровадити
підвищення мінімальної зарплати
та пенсійний вік з 60 років.
Новий союз очолює
колишній кандидат в президенти
Жан-Люк Меланшон.
Він - впевнений в перемозі.
Більшість Макрона хотіла, щоб перед виборами
всі перебували у глибокому сні,
ні про що не говорили і нікого не тривожили.
Вони можуть робити те, що хочуть,
але ми робимо це інакше
і тепер ми попереду, а вони - в паніці.
Якщо союз Nupes отримає більшість,
Меланшон сподівається стати новим прем'єрміністром.
Але Макрон не симпатизує конкурентові.
Це партія, що хоче заборон і
податок на високі прибутки.
Це не добре для нашої країни.
Хто отримає більшість?
За опитуваннями, партія Макрона і Nupes майже рівні.
Я голосую за Макрона.
Ні, ні, ти цього не зробиш.
Я забороняю тобі це робити,
Меланшон або ніхто.
Мало хто вдягає маску і тримає дистанцію.
Коронавірус зараз не відіграє
великої ролі для багатьох.
Проте Інститут Роберта Коха RКІ попереджає,
що через нові підтипи омікрона
інфекції можуть значно зрости влітку.
Ось яка ситуація наразі:
протягом 24 годин зареєстровано
77 878 нових випадків коронавірусу,
що на 35 185 більше, ніж тиждень тому.
Смертельних випадків -106.
Семиденний показник захворюваності - 318,7.
Постійна комісія з вакцинації наразі рекомендує
вакцинацію для груп ризику
і проти іншого вірусного захворювання.
Йдеться про мавпячу віспу.
На сьогодні в Німеччині
зареєстровано понад 130 випадків
зараження вірусом мавпячої віспи.
Подробиці розповість Фабіан Келер
і Крістіна Іглзедер.
Вже багато років професор Рейнгольд Ферстер
з медичного університету Ганноверу працює
над створенням вакцини проти віспи.
За словами імунолога, мавпяча віспа не є чимось новим.
Проте наразі спостерігаємо новий спосіб передачі інфекції.
Інфекція передавалася від тварин до людей,
від мавп до людей, від ховрахів до людей.
Новим є те, що інфекція
передається від людини до людини.
З травня в Німеччині зареєстровано
понад 130 випадків захворювання,
переважно в легкій формі.
Захворіти можуть чоловіки і жінки.
Нині хворіють переважно гомосексуальні чоловіки,
які брали участь у вечірках для гомосексуалістів.
Це не має нічого спільного зі
стигматизацією сексуальних вподобань,
а лише з поведінкою, яка несе підвищений ризик.
Мавпяча віспа, на відміну від коронавірусу,
передається переважно через тісний фізичний контакт
з пошкодженою шкірою або слизовими оболонками.
Тому Постійна комісія з вакцинації рекомендує вакцинацію
контактних осіб хворих,
а також чоловіків
з одностатевими сексуальними партнерами,
що часто змінюються.
Вакцинують звичайною вакциною проти віспи,
яка захищає і від мавпячої віспи,
навіть після зараження.
На відміну від коронавірусу, pизик зараження невисокий,
адже мутації мавпячої віспи, на думку експертів, малоймовірні.
Це не РНК-вірус, а
подвійний штам ДНК вірусу.
Вони надзвичайно стабільні.
За словами лікаря, нинішні випадки -
не привід для паніки, а привід для пильності.
В університеті у Хамм-Ліппштадті, Вестфалія,
34-річний чоловік поранив ножем 4 людей,
деякі з них знаходяться в тяжкому стані.
Згідно з першими висновками поліції,
злочинець напав на людей з ножем
в коридорах університету.
На шляху до лекційної зали
його спіймали студенти.
Мотиви злочину наразі невідомі.
А зараз - про футбол.
Норберте, щодо завтрашнього матчу
збірної Німеччини проти Угорщини.
Третій матч в Лізі націй.
Тренер збірної Німеччини Гансі Флік відчайдушно
хоче перемоги в Будапешті, щоб винагородити команду
за їхню самовіддачу та зусилля
після двох нічиїх проти Італії та Англії.
Серж Гнабрі зміг лише трохи потренуватися
через дискомфорт в ікрі.
Невідомо, чи зможе він завтра зіграти.
В Угорщині на команду Гансі Фліка
чекає складне завдання.
Після Англії - це найскладніша гра, яку можна провести.
Угорщини має
дуже компактну,
добре організовану в оборонному плані команду,
яка навряд чи так легко дасть пробити оборону.
Через велике навантаження,
пов'язане з чотирма матчами за 11 днів,
Флік закликає футбольні асоціації і союзи
переосмислити ситуацію та дати професіоналам
більше відпочинку.
Чотири гри – це забагато
після такого довгого сезону.
В якийсь момент потрібно просто запитати себе,
як можна дати гравцям перепочинок?
Він розкритикував напружений графік.
З іншого боку, команді потрібні матчі
для підготовки до Чемпіонату світу.
Дрезденське «Динамо»,
що вибуло з другого дивізіону,
тепер має Маркуса Анфанга як нового головного тренера.
47-річний  Анфанг уклав
із саксонцями дворічний контракт.
В листопаді Анфанг подав у відставку
з посади тренера бременського «Вердера»
після того, як стало відомо,
що він використав підроблений сертифікат про вакцинацію.
Німецький футбольний союз DFB наклав на Анфанга заборону,
яка від сьогодні набуває випробувального терміну.
Оскар Отте вийшов до наступного тенісного туру
в Штутгарті без боротьби.
Його суперник в чвертьфіналі був змушений
відмовитися від участі через біль в животі.
Уродженець Кельна завтра у півфіналі зустрінеться
з фіналістом торішнього Вімблдону
Маттео Берреттіні.
До Формули-1 і Гран-прі Азербайджану.
У другій вільній практиці найкращий час показав
пілот команди Ferrari Шарль Леклер.
Другим став Серхіо Перес з Red Bull,
а його одноклубник та чемпіон світу
Макс Ферстаппен зайняв третє місце.
Себастьяну Феттель на Aston Martin
довелося задовольнитися 11-м місцем.
Мік Шумахер фінішував передостаннім.
Це всі новини спорту.
Приємні перспективи -
погода дарує нам літній вікенд.
Подробиці незабаром з Крістою Орбен.
Марієтта Сломка та «heute journal» о 22:00.
Бажаю спокійного початку вихідних.
Дякую за перегляд і до завтра.
Добрий вечір.
Антициклон з Азорських островів
зробить ці вихідні справді літніми.
Проте його суперник, циклон з Ісландії,
який ми бачимо на супутникових знімках
як чудове кільце хмар,
втрутиться в сонячну погоду
і принесе кілька хмаринок, проте без опадів.
Сьогодні вночі вони будуть
на півночі та північному заході.
У інших регіонах - ясно,
вночі температура становитиме від 12° до 15°,
ближче на південь - до 7-11°.
Завтра найпрохолодніше буде на узбережжях: від 19-22°
зі свіжим, поривчастим західним вітром.
Але, загалом, температура буде приємною -
від 23-26°.
В Брайсгау можливо навіть до 30°.
В напрямку південного заходу та північного заходу
завтра дуже сонячно.
Хмари найбільш ймовірні в регіонах
Нижнього та Середнього Рейну, Одера та Найсе,
Балтійського моря та Східної Баварії, місцями дощ.
Отож, очікується сприятлива погода.
В неділю буде більш сонячно,
особливо в центрі країни, а температура
коливатиметься від 19 до 30°.
Новий тиждень розпочнеться
на 3-4° прохолодніше з грозами.
Але у вівторок знову сухо.
Гарного вечора!